and welcome to Hannity and tonight
whatever you do just don't look up
that's the message from your president
the Biden Administration as thick black
toxic chemical smoke is polluting the
air over East Palestine and Ohio because
of a controlled chemical burn following
a trail a train derailment that they're
telling us very little about now today
two more trains derailed in South
Carolina and Texas and even more
troubling news since Friday three
unidentified objects have been shot down
after breaching U.S and Canadian
airspace that is four shoot Downs in
eight days one over Alaska and another
over the Yukon territory in Canada uh
yet another one over Lake Huron near
Michigan and according to your president
and government they have zero clue where
they came from and the head of NORAD is
even suggesting they could be
extraterrestrial this is what your
government is telling you now this all
comes after a massive Chinese spy
balloon went on a cross-country Joyride
over most of America her and had an
opportunity to look at America's most
sensitive military and nuclear weapons
sites before that F-22 down the balloon
near Myrtle Beach after it started in
Canada and Idaho and Montana then down
to Missouri in Kansas and up to Kentucky
and then to the Carolinas so what the
hell is going on here where is your
president why doesn't anybody have an
answer and why is President Biden
downplaying the significance he actually
was out there saying oh it's it's it's
not a major you know uh problem for most
people it's not a major breach
unfortunately the most transparent
Administration in history they don't
want to talk about it we didn't hear a
peep yet from Biden all day he called
the lid of course at 4 30 in the
afternoon and snap time we did however
get a short briefing from the Pentagon
yesterday during the Super Bowl but that
didn't tell us much at all they again
wouldn't even rule out the possibility
that these objects were extraterrestrial
in other words space aliens but just
hours ago White House Press Secretary
Kareem Jean-Pierre thought this was all
very funny I don't find it very funny
but you decide I just wanted to make
sure we addressed this from the White
House I know there have been questions
and and concerns about this but there is
no again no indication of aliens or
extraterrestrial activity with these
recent takedowns again there is no
indication of aliens or terrestrial
activity with these recent takedowns
wanted to make sure that the American
people knew that all of you knew that
and it was important for us to say that
from here because we've been hearing a
lot about it
um
I'm just you know I loved E.T the movie
but I'm just going to leave it there
actually we will talk to somebody a
pilot to testify before Congress that in
fact he did see an unidentified flying
object now we are talking about American
airspace it was breached on four
separate occasions in eight days and the
White House is laughing about it uh and
they don't even know where the other
three balloons objects even came from
where did they come from how did they
get here are we facing some kind of
threat from China or Russia or maybe
another hostile regime and what if
anything well the Biden Administration
do about this now of course the White
House is unable or unwilling to answer
any of those questions they're not even
keeping lawmakers and governors in the
loop for example here's Montana Senator
Steve daines who was on my radio show
today he's livid the lack of
communication from the Biden
Administration regarding the closing of
Montana airspace last night and the
recent shootdowns that took place over
Alaska and Canada is unacceptable even
Canada's cowardly prime minister little
Justin is more transparent at least he's
tweeting about the objects and
communicating with the people of Canada
Joe Biden is totally silent his Twitter
feed is filled with brainless political
lies about Republicans and Medicare and
Social Security and quote leading the
world again and yet Joe you know can't
be bothered to update we the American
people about three other new
unidentified objects breaching American
airspace being shot down by our military
or giving us the specifics on the
Chinese spy balloon that he waited eight
whole days to finally take out of the
sky now you might remember Joe said it
was too risky the reason he waited it
was too risky to shoot it down over the
continental United States or Alaska or
Canada it was better to just let China
spy on us for eight long days even
Chucky Schumer had a hard time defending
that position take a look but we got
enormous intelligence information from
surveilling the balloon as it went over
the United States get enormous
intelligence as well well they they
could have been getting it anyway but we
have to know what they're doing okay and
we don't know exactly but we got a lot
of that and even more importantly by
shooting it down over water U.S water is
only six miles out from South Carolina
we're going to probably be able to piece
together this whole whole uh
surveillance balloon and know exactly
what's going on so that's a huge coup
for the United States
it's a cool uh he even acknowledged that
they could have been getting
Intelligence on us now keep in mind we
only know about the balloon because it
was spotted by a local photographer on
the ground in Montana the White House
was more than happy to keep this whole
thing a secret that is uh if they even
knew about the balloon before the
civilian took pictures and spotted it
from the ground now meanwhile the last
three objects were shot down very
quickly over land apparently it was just
what the first Chinese spy balloon
opposed lose the risk to people on the
ground the more likely scenario was they
flat out lied to us use that as their
excuse for their incompetence not
shooting it down for eight days not
shooting it down immediately so we're
also learning that yet another object
likely another spy balloon from China
crashed off the coast of Hawaii four
months ago again why weren't we told
take a look at your screen these are
lasers beaming down from a Chinese
satellite over the Hawaiian Islands on
January 28th first I'm hearing about it
China knows that Joe Biden isn't willing
to do a thing they can smell his
weakness a mile away sadly they're
correct and Joe can't even bring himself
to reprimand the Communist Party in
China in public China has moved into the
Taiwan Straits tonight as we speak and
the Biden White House is telling
Americans they've got to leave Russia
immediately what was his Abacus his
family had all these business deals all
this money going back transactions with
China and Russian Rush Russia the
question is America needs to understand
this how much money did the Biden family
get from our number one geopolitical foe
China on number two geopolitical foe
Russia in these business deals involving
Hunter his partners and according to
Hunter half his income going up Pops how
much money are we talking about millions
billions how much and could it be
possible that at the end of the day that
this family and this President is
compromised now one can only imagine the
Intel and the dossiers that countries
like Russia and China have on Hunter
Biden alone remember that report from
the Senate Homeland Security committee
detailing multiple payments from Chinese
Nationals to the bidens including that
hundred thousand dollar shopping spree
other huge massive lucrative deals with
the CCP that includes that multi-million
dollar deal with the Chinese Energy
company according to the Washington Post
another massive deal with the Bank of
China according to the New York closed
captioning not available
that Podium and tell all of us what the
hell is going on if he even knows what's
going on hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else